there is an update with respect to unity
which those of you who have been
attending our campfires will know about
but the rest of you should know
so the unity 2020 plan involved a
proposal to draft candidates
to elect to the white house it came with
a pair of fail-safes to prevent it from
spoiling
the election one of those fail-safes was
if
as the election approached we did not
have a viable
path to victory we would pull the plug
on the plan so that it couldn't spoil
the election
and we have arrived the decision that
this is that moment
now were there to be some sort of
an emergency that would cause the
electorate to wake up to the danger that
we are in all of a sudden and to go
groping for a better plan
than the major parties have delivered us
the plan
could be rebooted but that is not our
expectation
so let me tell you a little bit about
what this does and doesn't mean
it means that we are not going to
attempt to draft our ticket
but what we have recognized in the
process of
working on unity 2020 is that the plan
is part of a larger movement and the
movement is one that
stands against the things that have
corrupted our governmental structure
and the need for it is
as great or greater than it was when we
started it so
the movement is going to continue we are
going to look
to the long term and attempt to figure
out how it is that we
can rescue our republic from the
death spiral that its political class
has inflicted upon it so that's where we
stand with unity 2020
not uh the best news but not hopeless
not an end well let me say i'm not even
it's not
the best news the best news would have
been
uh that come january 2021 we are
welcoming a unity ticket to the white
house
and uh it looks like god all the color
metaphors you can imagine a light at the
end of the tunnel blue skies overhead
all of this i mean as we said in our in
our founding document
imagine that a pair of courageous
capable patriots were
ascending to be sworn in how what kind
of you know sigh of relief
relief would the country collectively
breathe and so that was always
the objective on the other hand i would
point out that you know you and i have
talked a lot in the context
of education and in the context of other
phenomena about the importance of a
prototyping
mindset and that's right everything good
that is complex
arises through an iterated process of
discovery
right i should look up whether or not
edison in fact
said that at the point that uh he
had succeeded he had discovered a
thousand ways not to make a light bulb
or something to that effect
but the point is we discovered a
tremendous amount
in this process about what needs to take
place in order to fix
the uh the corruption that has uh
disrupted
governments and there's there is a
tremendous amount
of of goodwill and pressure and force in
in the right in the you know physics
sense of the term
um behind this you know it was it was
apparent that there is
as you and i and many others have long
suspected
a real visceral
intellectual and emotional desire to see
a fix
and that fix might well look like this
yeah it really
lacked one thing which was uh
exponential
growth which you know in some sense is
the thing
on the other hand what it did do was
surface
the the underlying belief structure of a
great many patriots
and so you know does it set the stage
for us to do something in the future
that could in fact
recapture the white house or other
structures on behalf of the people
i think it revealed the path there and
so you know personally
i um i
feel imperiled to know that what is very
likely to happen
is you know we were going to get one the
the duopoly's version a or b right
that's a very frightening prospect
um and i wish we i wish somebody had
figured out a way out of that mess
didn't happen so okay that's frightening
on the other hand
i'm not the least bit disappointed at
what happened here
i think we beat expectations by a lot
right we ran a successful ranked choice
vote we had high level discussions with
lots of people both
you know on our campfires and behind the
scenes and so
we did discover that the niche in
question exists and the question is
what do you do with it so we will see
going forward but uh
if you have been following unity 2020
please know
that uh what has changed is the unity
2020 plan itself
the unity movement still exists and is
as dedicated as ever to the prospect of
fixing our system
perhaps something like unity 2020 is
dead
long live unity i like that i wouldn't
say dead it's uh
unity 2020 yeah is dead this was about a
particular moment in time
right this is about a particular
presidential election appending the 2020
to it
so just like the king is dead long live
the king refers to two different
instantiations of the king
uni 2020 is presumably not the name of
the movement going forward because
it pinpoints the origin date and it's a
forward-looking movement
right yeah my concern was not with the
unity 2020 part it's with
dead because the prototype mindset i
you know is it dead but it doesn't
matter it's a semantic question
there are multiple lenses with which to
approach something and i
obviously agree with the prototype lens
but using a phrase from history doesn't
render the prototype lens inoperable
right
except that you have neglected the fact
that history is itself a tool of
oppression and therefore we must
you know that's cheating i'm kidding i
know it was only a joke
all right so that's the unity 2020
update the unity movement continues this
is
we're trying to model this right like
when people pull that [ __ ] on you that's
cheating
stop right and the way you really stop
them is the eyebrows the
double raised eyebrow thing that's a
shot across the bow so
all right maybe a slight eye roll and a
slack jaw oh god
oh yeah yeah the eye roll and the up to
the right thing
man yeah that is uh that's a warning